it is in this nature of what is to be in
its being its own notion that logical
necessity in general consists this alone
is the rational element and the rhythm
of the organic hole it is as much
knowledge of the content as the content
is the notion and essence in other words
it alone is speculative philosophy the
self moving concrete shape makes itself
into a simple determinate 'no since Oh
doing it raises itself to logical form
and exists in its essentiality its
concrete existence is just this movement
and is directly illogical existence it
is for this reason unnecessary to close
the content in an external logical
formalism the content is in its very
nature the transition into such
formalism but a formalism which ceases
to be external
since the form is the innate development
of the concrete content itself
in this section number 56 and in several
of the ones that are going to
immediately follow Hegel is telling us
about necessity again and also telling
us why it's it's not only not needed but
a bad idea to approach all of these
these matters that the phenomenology is
going to be a phenomenology that is a
viewing a sort of systematic watching
and putting putting these things
together why it's a bad idea to approach
this in a formalist schematic way as
we've seen him reject before so why is
that he's saying that logical necessity
and first night of the English that I
have the German here logical necessity
and as such consists in some way in a
being beginning its own notion and you
know there's one of those those phrases
where we said well I got you up to this
point what are you actually talking
about here and it's tempting very often
I know this temptation myself when you
get you know weird Hegel's going in
general and you understand bits and
pieces of the of the systematic approach
that seem very attractive and you want
to get to later chapters where you know
more is going on to say well you know I
don't really get this but I'm sure it'll
become clear as I go along and then
never come back to it so we don't want
to do that here making it even more
murky I've got the actual German for it
and it's sort of a tongue twister in
Zion Zion Zion beginneth design this is
what it is for a thing to actually you
know Express or or entail logical
necessity in seinem zine that is in its
being zine Bhagirath its notion
translated here or its concept zoos I
to be so - for its being to be its
concept and I think if you put it that
way it becomes a little bit more
clearing out what this is saying is
logical necessity is we're being and
concept are finally if not coinciding
because sign here doesn't have to be to
be doesn't have to be seen as a cure
identity statement but rather to say
that these are actually aligned with
each other in such a way that the the
concept reveals to us the being the
being is revealing itself through our
very engagement with it through the
concept and the concept is not related
to the being in an arbitrary way but in
a necessary way it is expressing what it
is for that being to be which is for it
to be the kind of being that it is the
the concept of that being hopefully
that's you know totally clear now
probably not though right so it says
this is what speculative philosophy
really consistent he tells us a few
other things that help us sort of fill
in you know the gaps unless he says the
content is the notion and the essence so
so what it is that you know the being is
its content what we can say about it
what we can know about it is the this
notion this this systematic grasp beyond
the essence when we when we've actually
you know made it to figuring out what
something is we are grasping its essence
the content that word were engaged in in
knowledge of the content as well and
these two in one sentence are connected
together so knowledge of the content
involves this being the case that the
content is the notion and the essence we
don't want to say well therefore
knowledge is of the the concept because
it's a little bit more tricky than that
why well because what he's calling
shapes here translating the term Gestalt
self moving concrete or not it's
actually singular sorry self moving the
self moving concrete shape makes itself
into a determinist at the logical
structure of earlier this self other in
process that involves becoming
determinate and sort of taking this back
into itself we could look at this in a
multiple different you know modes
abstraction turns out to be not just
identity pure identity but also non
identity because the thing is not the
same thing as the extraction of it but
it's related to it all of these give us
a fuller and fuller conception of the
thing they do contribute knowledge to us
now he says as the self moving concrete
Gestalt or a form or shape makes itself
into a determinate Nasir's where it gets
really interesting
it raises itself into logical for so
another way of looking at this would be
that when we are actually as
phenomenologist as you know those
engaging in this historical inquiry into
consciousness and consciousness as
objects when we're actually being
attentive when we're not just sort of
super imposing our own preconceived
notions on to this then the content
itself will give us clues about how it
want to be schematized
how it ought to be arranged and you
don't have to be Hagel to figure this
out I mean all you really have to do is
be involved with any sort of craft work
and and you know
where there's material and you'll
realize very quickly that whatever you
came to the material with whatever
preconceived ideas about how it's going
to work and how it ought to work
if those happen to align with the
realities of the material good for you
otherwise the material is going to kick
it back to you and say I'm not doing
that I'm doing what I want to do and if
you want to come along for the ride
here's what you can do I mean you can
think about a carving crews ample wood
carving you carve generally with the
grain you you know you can of course
chisel against the grain and there's all
sorts of you know special cuts you can
do but if you're if you're trying to
just approach the material from the
outside and say you're gonna do exactly
this what you may as well just be
pouring concrete then right or doing
plastic molding rather than actually
working with something that has its own
grain its own texture its own structure
to it and so he goes saying things will
give us their logical structure so he
says kind of create existence is just
this movement and is directly illogical
existence we're experiencing this long
before we even if we never decide to
come to Hegel's phenomenology or even
philosophy in general this is part of
what it is to be human is to be
attentive to things out there sometimes
you know it's it's superimposing our own
consumption sound to it he's not saying
never do that but he is saying that a
lot of our concrete existence is
learning from the objects hey this is
how I am supposed to be understood this
is the kind of thing that I am sir says
it's it's unnecessary to close a content
in an external logical formalism the
content is in its very nature the
transition into such formalism but a
formalism that ceases to be external so
I see Hegel's not against formalism per
se he's against formalism that doesn't
take its cues from that
just to be formalized that is the
objects the the content that is supposed
to be grasped for consciousness by means
of the the notion so he says the form is
the innate development to the concrete
content itself as these things expose
themselves to us and and we engage with
them
and many of these things by the way are
human realities not just just say
material things or natural objects we
are ourselves learning how to
conceptualize them how to bring them
into the notion and this is not just us
you know sort of sitting back and the
ideas popping in our head Hegel things
we're actually in a relationship with
the thing and learning about what is in
that thing now it exists for us and our
thought as we put it out earlier this is
an idealism so that you know it's not as
if the alien thing is way out there and
as you know we're sort of realizing
what's inside of it that we would never
otherwise have had access to but it's
not just all on our side it's it's also
on the side of the thing
this nature of scientific method which
consists partly and not being separate
from the content and partly and
spontaneously determining the rhythm of
its movement has has already remarked
its proper exposition and speculative
philosophy of course what has been said
here does express the notion but cannot
count for more than an anticipatory
assurance its truth does not lie in this
partly narrative exposition and is
therefore just as little refuted by
asserting the contrary by calling to
mind and recounting conventional ideas
as if they were established in familiar
truths or by dishing up something new
with the assurance that it comes from
the shrine of inner divine intuition a
reception of this kind is usually the
first reaction on the part of knowing to
something unfamiliar it resists it in
order to save its own freedom and its
own insight its own authority from the
alien Authority for this is the guys in
which what is newly encountered first
appears and to get rid of the appearance
that something has been learned and have
the sort of shame this is supposed to
involve similarly where the unfamiliar
is greeted with applause the reaction is
of the same kind and consists in what
another sphere would take the form of
ultra revolutionary speech and action
in section 57 Hale is going to once
again you know contrast the scientific
method that's entailed and speculative
philosophy in dialectical you know
conceptual philosophy against a few
other rivals you could say that are that
are prevalent not only in his culture
but also in our own and we'll come to
those in a moment but I actually want to
skip ahead a little bit towards the the
bottom of the paragraph because he's
talking about something that happens
when we encounter forms of thought that
are unfamiliar to us he says that a
reception of this kind is usually the
first reaction on the part of knowing so
somebody who already is engaged in you
know knowledge some systematization some
putting things together their first
reaction to something unfamiliar and not
just unfamiliar in the sense of well
here's a new content and I you know I
haven't encountered this before you know
welltake it's a very trivial example
bubblegum you know when I was a kid
there were just a few cuttings of gum at
first and then there was this bubble gum
explosion and you know not only did we
have bubble gum flavor but also cherry
flavor and grape flavor and we thought
this is so great you know bubblicious
and hubba bubba came out and then after
a while they started going hog-wild with
that and just you know interesting all
theirs are crazy flavors and you know
some of us said that's enough
yeah there's too many crazy flavors you
know peach that's fine but this this
thing over here I don't even know what
that what that's supposed to be here
what it's supposed to taste like I think
you just mixed a bunch of chemicals
together and you know in the ad industry
they say throw it at the wall and see if
it sticks that's what they think they
did and so I could be a you know I've
got knowledge about bubblegum and this
is not you know scientific knowledge in
the sense that I'm you know analyzing it
in the lab but you know experiential
knowledge right I'm a kid who you know
which
shell out money so there's a stake in it
four different flavors of bubblegum and
we would compare notes among the kids so
there's a process of inquiry going on
there right and you know since I'm
paying money for it it actually matters
to me if I'm gonna buy this pack I want
to know that that's actually going to
taste like something decent and you know
maybe you somebody else buys a pack you
know I'll swap you on for one because
the packs always had five big cubes of
gum in them and now you try it you're
like what the hell is this that's new
content right it's not requiring you to
sort of radically change your way of
understanding things it's just new
content it's it's adding a little bit to
your knowledge base in this this one
area
now there's other kinds of knowledge
there's other objects of knowledge which
call more into question you can think of
them as having sort of a ripple effect
where this is new and if this is new and
it's something real and it's something I
do need to take into account that's
gonna call into question a lot of these
these other things as well think about
when you first tell somebody about the
the notion of emotional intelligence and
you don't even break it down for them
while it consists in being able to
identify your emotions being able to
identify other people's emotions having
some rudimentary knowledge of how
emotions work you know being able to
sort of empathize with other people
project how they're going to feel you
know there's a whole bunch of different
components to this once you start to
learn about this people often have those
you know white bulb going on moments and
they say oh yeah now that I understand
this
I've been misunderstanding this stuff
over here all this time now that's a
positive reaction Hegel talks about
negative reactions that people have to
that sort of thing as well he says it
resists it in order to save its own
freedom and its own insight a lot of
times when people encounter a new way of
looking at things they want to they say
can't fit into what I already know I
don't want to know about it why because
it makes them feel unfree and it makes
them feel like they don't know what
they're actually doing and the more that
people have invested in self when Hagen
would call self certainty at this height
the more damaging this is to the stance
that they're currently in the more you
know frightening it is for their shape
of consciousness to the point where it
could actually you know and do such
anxiety that it counts as something like
the you know the fear of death that's
going to be talked about later on in the
the self consciousness section so Hegel
is isolating two elements here he is
saying they want to preserve their own
freedom because there is a freedom in
thinking that he's going to talk about a
lot in the next sections and they want
to preserve their own insight their own
authority from the alien authority the
alien authority the new way of looking
at things is coming in as an alien
Authority and saying well you didn't you
didn't have it all figured out and as a
matter of fact we're probably have to
retool quite a bit of your stock here
and you know it's gonna be a bit
disruptive for a while
how long well we don't know we have to
see how it just helps how badly off you
actually are so they want to like he
says get rid of the appearance that
something has been learned another sort
of shame or embarrassment of feeling
lower that this is supposed to involve
learning requires humility you know the
landlord does docility literally means
teach abilities somebody who is not
docile somebody who is not open and
receptive really can't be taught in an
awful lot certainly nothing that matters
you know particularly and oftentimes we
need to shake them up a bit in order to
be able to do that and speculative
philosophy was gonna shake him up so he
says speculative philosophy works with
the notion I'm giving you an outline
here I'm getting
sort of a narration I'm not saying that
this is the whole shebang so don't read
the preface and say well what about this
and what about this and what about this
we'll get to that later on but I'm
giving you the main the main outlines
what are people going to oppose to that
he says well you know two things quite
quick coming common conventional ideas
things that are already established
taken as being true and as you know sort
of environment that we have to work in
well this this isn't really you know
worth doing because my philosophy
teacher told me that Hegel is too hard
and incomprehensible and nobody really
works with him anyway except for a few
weird wacky continental people well it'd
be an example of a conventional idea a
lot of people do have that idea can you
do anything with it yeah you can reject
Hegel and save yourself the time of
actually reading something is it an
adequate approach to things not really
you you probably need to check it I mean
if you're actually curious about whether
there's anything to this you actually
have to spend the time do the work and
think it through and then you're
probably gonna find out that those
conventional ideas not only are false
but I actually have a place within the
phenomenology where Hegel can actually
tell you how and why they're false
that's one of the things that's
interesting by this perspective also
people like like Alistair McIntyre who
is in a certain way go in in what he
does influence through calling and of
course another thing that people do is
they come up with something new
something that's a little bit easier to
grasp but doesn't have the same grasp
ability or comprehensibility the same
the grief of the kites the Griffin is to
grasp right to sink your claws into to
get a hold of and there's some things
that appear superficially graspable they
sound implausible and they sound cool
quite often but really there's not a lot
to them and you know people will say
well you either got to get it
you don't get it man and that's you know
what higgles calling intuition
he says they come up with something new
by intuition if we want to be very
facetious we you know we talk about
people pulling things out of their their
rear ends that's what he's talking about
there and those are both responses that
people will have so that they don't have
to do this kind of work over here
what they're for is in
important in the study of science is
that one should take on oneself the
strenuous effort of the notion this
requires attention to the notion as such
to the simple determinations that is a
being as such being for itself
self-identity
and so forth for these are pure self
movements such as could be called souls
if their notion did not designate
something higher than soul the habit of
picture thinking when it isn't
interrupted by the notion finds it just
as arsim as those formalistic thinking
that argues back and forth and thoughts
that have no actuality that habit should
be called material thinking a contingent
consciousness that is absorbed only in
material stuff and therefore finds it
hard work to lift the thinking self
clear of such matter and to be with
itself alone at the opposite extreme
argumentation is freedom from all
content and a sense of vanity towards it
what is look for here is the effort to
give up this freedom and instead of
being the arbitrary arbitrarily moving
principle of the content to sink this
freedom in the content letting it move
spontaneously of its own nature by the
self as its own self and then to
contemplate this movement this refusal
to intrude into the imminent rhythm of
the notion either arbitrarily or with
wisdom obtained from elsewhere
constitutes a restraint which is itself
an essential moment of the notion
in Section 58 Hegel is going to contrast
three different approaches against each
other these are ones that actually play
a very important role you might say in
his history of thought and for Stella or
for Stalin the verb or the now they play
an important place along the way he also
identifies we're just going hear
argument argumentation or raisiny read
with sort of the the philosophy of the
understanding so if you actually go on
to look through Hegel's other works
you're going to find these playing a
very important role as preliminary steps
that don't realize that their
preliminary steps and that's why they
end up being insufficient so he tells us
that science mission shaft requires the
strenuous effort of the notion it means
that we have to work not only to you
know penetrate into the content and
allow the content to speak to us to
dictate its own categories to us but we
have to be even more rigorous with
respect to this it can't just be a sort
of Mandans you know the oceans going to
talk to me about what kind of thing it
is we have to conceptualize it we have
to try to to grasp it it's it's an
active process both ways and so he
actually brings up some metaphysical
determinations in this what he called
simple determinations examples of these
are being in itself what is being in
itself well that requires an analysis
and it turns out you know here's the
punch line for everything a galleon
everything that you analyze always turns
out to be something quite different than
what you originally thought it was so
being in itself being for itself
self-identity he says these are pure
self movements such as could be called
souls because they are self moving right
the soul is self moving in traditional
philosophy if their notion did not
designate something
higher than in salt now he doesn't talk
about this but I think that we also
ought to read into this strenuousness of
the effort the notion that we're also
entering into the content of the notion
it's concreteness he's just been talking
about this he perhaps doesn't think that
he needs to talk about at this point you
know r.e.m ffice eyes it but i think
that given the nature of this you know
sort of course it's worth emphasizing
that these to go along with each other
these simple determinations like being
in itself are getting used to illuminate
the concrete actualities the
experiential things that we're running
into that's the content of the notion
now he says science has to do a lot of
work to develop you know sort of
systematic understanding of these things
that it can actually justify to itself
and he opposes two other types of
thinking to this so he talked about
picture of thinking first he says they
habit of picture thinking when it's
interrupted by the notion finds it
arrghh them as does formalistic thinking
that argues back and forth and thoughts
that have no actualities that's that's
more than raise them near now picture
thinking is when people actually have a
very determinate understanding of things
and this could be very important things
you know an example of this is in the
lectures on the the philosophy of
religion
picture thinking actually takes you
quite a ways but we have to get beyond
that to two conceptual thinking towards
the the notion the concept and what he
highlights here is the fact that picture
thinking thinks in terms of images these
don't necessarily have to be visual
images these could be verbalizations
these could be things that are heard
imaginations you know and he talks about
it in terms of habits and he says it
should be called material thinking
a contingent consciousness that has
absorbed only immaterial stuff therefore
finds it hard work to lift the thinking
self clear of such mannered to be with
itself alone thinking in these sorts of
determinations of the concept and he's
right about this very often when people
are doing picture thinking take for
example the notion of freedom people
have a very determinate conception of
freedom they belong to a political party
or political movement and here we're
dealing with an idea but it's also
probably tied in with some some
emotional resonances with some very
determinate you know understandings of
this is freedom that's not freedom and
then they encounter somebody else who
has a different conception for them
because there's there's multiple
conceptions and they find themselves
unable to engage in the back-and-forth
and very long and they find themselves
having to sort of just reinforce their
position they find others who agree with
them who are part of that community you
know we understand freedom they don't
they don't get it and you can see this
playing itself out in American politics
all the time and you know right and left
and the coalition's that represent them
the Republican and Democratic parties
both of them have you know very partial
understandings of what freedom choice
common good any of these sorts of ideas
actually there Hegel would say that
there both of them are actually deeply
mired in alternative varieties of
picture thinking on the other hand
critique argumentation what he's calling
raisin gear in here offers a kind of
freedom from content but in a certain
way it goes too far it is a freedom that
he says actually leads to a kind of
vanity a sense of vanity towards it it
can never commit itself to anything he
says what is look for here is the effort
to give up this freedom so you know
what's missing here on the side of
picture thinking on for Stella is it
hasn't done the work to free itself from
its contingency over here
there's the you know freedom to say well
it's all contingent and that itself can
end up being a sort of paralyzing stance
to take by which and you know a person
doesn't progress because they can
anything that that comes along they can
negate they can say well that's not
everything that's you know got some
flaws and then they never actually do
the the work of jumping in and seeing
where things actually go and then
looking at it critically again so he
says what they need to do is to sink
this freedom and the content letting it
move spontaneously of its own nature by
the self as its own self then to
contemplate its movements so what you
could think of is I don't want to say
you know thesis antithesis synthesis
because it's not so simple as that you
know which of these is the thesis
neither one is actually the thesis and
both of them are the thesis but what
Hegel is calling science is supposed to
do is combine what's actually good in
both of these and strip away the
elements that are bad in in both of them
and attain something that actually gets
us along further so he says this refusal
to intrude into the imminent rhythm of
the notion either arbitrarily or with a
wisdom obtained from elsewhere
constitutes a restraint which is itself
an essential moment the notion so it's
it's not just you know go full-bore and
we're gonna figure everything out there
is a rhythm to phenomenology there is a
restraint that's required a it's sort of
like you know we're gonna do some
picture thinking here and we think about
it in terms of eating and you know diet
you know Dietetics and managing ones
ones food intake you know you sit there
and you eat and if you eat fast you're
probably not going to digest stuff very
well and be not tell how much you're
eating and probably overeat so you eat a
little bit more slowly and then just
actually start to notice the flavors of
things
you say well that's that actually has an
aftertaste
wait that's got to aftertaste oh now I
see why this dish goes at this one
because they actually pair well what
we're talking about as McGriff here
concept starts to unfold itself to us
when we're receptive to it and show a
kind of restraint and don't insist on
you know relying on just one of these
things but actually start piecing things
together and that can take a long time I
am perhaps less optimistic than Hagel
about you know the endpoint for that and
see it as an ongoing process that's
that's never quite finished myself but I
do think it's an advance especially at
this moment for him to criticize picture
thinking to tell us about that and the
counter calls to it is raised on the era